[Music]
china won't show you shooting hoops
unless you're one of their media dupes
and the nb plays nba plays along because
the revenue stream is so strong the
boston celtics who i'm told played
basketball and not flutes cat
have been pulled from chinese media
after celtic players
celtic player
anis cantor called for tibetan
independence
under the chinese government's brutal
rule tibetan people's basic rights and
freedoms are non-existent
they are not allowed to study and learn
their language and culture freely
they are not allowed to travel freely
they are not allowed to access
information freely
the tibetan people are not even allowed
to worship freedom brutal dictator of
china
xi jinping i have a message for you and
your henchman free tibet free tibet
free tibet
ennis is now a menace
now that stance is illegal in china they
don't like any calls for freedom unless
it's the freedom to enslave uyghurs to
make shoes for basketball players
so on wednesday chinese streaming giant
10 cent
cut the live broadcast between the
knicks and the celtics it was almost as
fast as the white house cutting the feed
when biden starts answering questions
so why does this matter well because
china reportedly accounts for at least
10 percent of the nba's revenues so the
league is reluctant to piss off the
dictatorship
two years ago nba executive darryl moray
tweeted support for democracy in hong
kong and his team's games are still
banned from tv there maury later
apologized likely pressured by the nba
to do so
plus the nba and other american
companies like nike who rely on china to
sustain their growth have pretty much
ignored beijing's
human rights record
supporting tearing down 100 year old
statues of slave owners is one thing
but publicly opposed the actual slavery
we're profiting off of in 2021 don't
look at us
maybe the nba is just waiting to see
which pronouns the slaves prefer before
releasing a statement
meanwhile instead of celtic games china
plans to show this instead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bird's got some balls
kennedy you are a friend of ennis yes
um this is this i mean it i i can say it
it takes balls and it definitely puts
him it juxtaposes him from some of the
other players
i mean
the level of courage it takes for him uh
this is someone whose entire family
essentially has been imprisoned in
turkey because he has spoken out against
uh the the turkish dictatorship of uh um
president erdogan there uh and and they
have been horrific he he cannot speak to
his family he cannot see them
they would love for him to go play in a
country where he can be extradited so
they could throw him in prison and he he
knows what he's up against he knows he's
putting his reputation and his career on
the line but he really spends his time
and and puts uh his mouth where the
danger is and he stands up yeah
but he stands up for people who are
truly oppressed and you know he's not
only standing up against lebron james
but the celtics who benched him right
during that game because he was wearing
a pair of shoes that were painted by a
chinese artist that said free tibetan
had a picture of a person in immolation
who had set themselves on fire which is
what people the raging gets better yes
yeah yeah i'm sure if he had kneeled it
might have been a different story if in
fact this is your wheelhouse so feel
free to answer whatever question is
already in your head well
yeah i mean what you said about kneeling
it's a it doesn't take a lot of courage
to kneel when everybody else is kneeling
during the national anthem or to paint
black lives matter on the court this guy
took courage and i respect that and i
think that the thing i want to watch for
because i think china is the single
greatest threat to the integrity of the
united states in the free world over the
next 10 years i think they're going to
invade taiwan i think it's going to be
early 2023 that's my prediction right
before the next presidential election
because they're not going to take that
risk i want to see what the nba says now
we know somebody who's going to actually
stand up i remember lebron james when
daryl mori sent that tweet he was the
first person to come to china's public
defense exactly these corporate and
celebrity cronies of of china are really
in the nba and every celebrity john cena
recently shamelessly apologizing to
china for the sin of calling taiwan a
country but this is this is this is
everywhere so this is a guy who actually
stands up to the system and i got to
give him a little bit of credit for that
more people are going to need to do it
though because if we don't make
sacrifices for the gold that we seek in
china their trick is going to work where
they build the great chinese wall that
prevents you from entering the market if
you criticize the ccp this is a guy
who's willing to make that sacrifice
yeah god this uh this show is full of
heroes there's me
and those other people
uh
cat
how soon before the nba like forces this
guy to apologize and the question is
will he yeah i don't think he gives
because by doing this it's not like
there's going to be no consequences he
already knows that you know it's not
like lebron james for example is under
the impression that china's good he just
knows that doing what he does and saying
what he says is good for his own bottom
line right so he knows he's missing out
on those things if you're gonna actually
proactively go out and do this he's not
gonna apologize or take it back yeah you
played in the nba didn't you tom i would
have loved it i would have loved it yeah
you're not quite tall enough are you no
i'm not yeah we're good enough but
no i think this guy's great it is
amazing that we are because he is a hero
but it's amazing what what it takes to
be a hero now just stating the obvious
yeah that's true so simple and maury
this guy he is now i think he's with
philadelphia they don't show
philadelphia's games either in china so
they don't have the celtics in china
they're not in philadelphia all it takes
is one player to speak up and then
they're blacklisting the team that's why
we need other heroes like this to state
the obvious i mean maury all he even
said if i remember correctly was we
stand with the people of hong kong right
and then the nba apologized i mean
that's the cowardice i hate to pick on
the players even though i love to pick
on lebron because he is a coward but the
the nba
i mean because he's a real hack and a
flack for the the chinese communist
party but the nba the it's the corporate
hacks i don't know any of their names
but they're all a bunch of jerks and uh
watch your mouth i mean it's a family
show
[Laughter]
it's amazing
go ahead go ahead finish your time we
have to you know essentially that's
where we end up going is we end up
blaming the players who aren't standing
up but the whole that it's the corporate
cowards of the nba and we should let
them know that we don't like what
they're doing yeah the problem is we
like our sports
so we kind of like we go yeah yeah yeah
and then we watch the games that's why
i'm i've picketed the nba i don't watch
the game i don't watch the game i watch
the game i don't watch any of the sports
i watch all the games i watch all the
games for you oh i'm sorry i thought
this was america no that my point is i
never watch anything so it's like a fake
boycott yeah it's like it's like i like
to boycott things i never really yeah
yeah i wasn't watching them anyway but
now i'm not watching it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else